JD left a Super Bowl party early because
he was so pissed off about losing bets
to Robin
he's never betting on the show again JD
why were you like I saw my fault you
were like mad at Robin
man no Maddie you guys did you lose $150
yeah you lost 150 you know what I lost I
lost the bet that Doritos yeah yeah I
know I won big they're [ __ ] here
Doritos has a commercial on like the
first half no no the way this year until
the second half it was Doritos versus
hot pasta pop-tarts and I thought the
Rito's would be first
I knew she must've known well I won on
the Kansas City Chiefs I bet them
I won that too you didn't bet the Kansas
City Chiefs I only did two bets
oh you only did that and [ __ ] Shakira
then doing hips don't lie
yeah I told you you were gonna lose I
was stupid I know yeah she'd come out
with hips don't lie by the way I was not
happy you want your money now how much
did you lose
$150 I guess I should we know it for lap
dances a private room actually for a
half hour yeah so upset he texted me
turn the cake he was so upset did you
swear off betting on the show you're
never gonna bet any I don't want to bet
any more on this where would I get all
my money Robin I lose and I don't watch
more money than you did listen I just
don't like I don't like betting a lot a
period and just this whole thing just I
didn't want I really did I shouldn't
have vetted Shakira I don't know what
the hell I was thinking
and just Doritos I was so sick I knew
Doritos this guy knew it I knew Doritos
was gonna get an ad in there they
[ __ ] didn't when you see the word bet
in past tense what do you say bed added
added [ __ ] yeah shouldn't have bet it
yeah well okay all right thank you
listen look at me can you learn anything
out of this
I should I should I should not have bet
I should not have bet on Doreen augury
toes man somebody's got to pull that
long I don't even want to eat Doritos
anymore